à sur les médecins c'est maurice
benhamou quelle surprise maurice
benhamou il est malade il est pas bien
et il pas l'accent copains explique
fabien et ton j'ai eu la gorge qui est
prise en ce moment je suis malade et où
il échoue nicki minaj pas bien et
symbolique il dit mais va voir le
docteur et devenant le docteur c'est
beaucoup trop cher en ce moment c'est
une catastrophe les affaires j'ai plus
un centime oui mais tu rigoles va voir
le docteur cohen
quand tu vas le voir une fois la
deuxième fois il te fait 50%
moi je sais dire ah bon c'est vrai ça
les connaît une crise benhamou universel
d'autocad et notaire me revoilà ça se
passe dans un cours de philosophie
voilà le profit dia bouder bouder genre
toi tu es dans le cours de philo the
west non c'est pas d'accord la nouvelle
de prendre à bouder à bouder si tu
marches dans la rue et tu trouves de
sacs un sac où il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent et 1,5 où il ya beaucoup
d'intelligence
quel sac tu prends à bouder débat c'est
normal je prends l'argent monsieur il ya
ba tu vois moi j'aurais pris
l'intelligent et bout d un débat chacun
prend ce qu'il n'a pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est à ces nanas qui arrêtent pas de
tromper son mari à chaque fois à le
tromper merle un péché mignon c'est
qu'elle adore les fruits et son mari ils
se doutent d'un truc tu vois qu'il est
en planque est le premier amant qui
arrivent ils tapent à la porte
elle ouvre dit mais c'est toi non mais
faut pas parce que je crois que mon mari
est au courant dit mais écoute c'est
quoi je te ramener les meilleures
raisons c'est le plus beau raison
j'étais chercheur rage ici la personne
qui les a bien raison les raisons 30 30
et en ce moment ils vont se mettre au
lit ça tape à la porte nord quels sont
le parquet surtout pas car c'est
sûrement bombardé de questions d'emploi
car le mec c'était dans le placard et
louvre la porte c'est son deuxième maman
ait dit ça lui serait due au mélange
veux pas revenir sur mon mari dit
regarde ça a mené les plus belles pommes
et viennent du japon
c'est pas moi c'est bien fait durant
dans la chambre il la jette dans les
liens se jette dans l'ue au moment où
ils vont se mettre à l'acte sa frappe à
la porte la question non pas car c'est
sûrement mon mari elle ouvre la porte
elle est comme ça sera mis elle voit
c'est son troisième maman il avec une
grosse pastèque
c'est pour toi tu mènes on regarde leur
nez du maroc sa plus belle a dit cette
pastèque mon dieu rend dans la chambre
met au lit au moment où ils vont se
mettent à l'acte sa frappe à la porte a
dit c'est sûrement mon mari devant la
gare dans le troisième pack à escale
dans le placard et louvre c'est son mari
dit je crois que j'ai pas vu tout ce
manège
tous ces hommes qui rentrent avec des
sacs dit maintenant tu te trompes sais
pas c'était des livres cd livres sont
maintenant je vais les buts et ils sont
où il ouvre le premier plat car ils
trouvent le mec avec les réseaux de bus
en supplie ne me tuez pas faites ce que
vous voulez mais ne me tuez pas edit je
veux pas te tuer et prendre chaque
grappe de raisin et je vais les mettre
dans ton budget il faut chaque grappe
aimé dans son unique le métier repart en
marchant moi ton comme ça merci monsieur
il les un placard et trouve le mec
inquiète pas de vieux plein de cuba j'ai
de faire la même chose de prendre chaque
fois mais il ouvre le troisième placard
et trouve les mecs entre le groupe la
pastèque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'où vient cette blague comment il avait
confié sa joie c'est écrit que c'est du
vécu et on a une on est maurice mais
bien sûr on l'a toujours eue maurice
mais la mode côté c est maurice benhamou
qui a un rendez-vous hyper important
pour le business et il est dans sa
voiture et il voit sa montre il dit
quand je vais être en retard je vais
être en retard ils trouvent pas de place
pour se garer c'est une catastrophe si
les mecs en plus sont hyper pointu et
toucher des japonais vont jamais
maintenant dix vont se barrer
concessions il cherche il trompa pas s'y
trouvent pas de place ici je vais rater
ça un vent dé bouygues perd importante
des taux est l'armé randonnée les trouve
toujours pas de placer dit mon dieu je
t'en supplie si jamais tu me libère une
place tout de suite c'est un don de 200
mille euros à la synagogue et la
notament seul coup il ya une place comme
par magie qui seibert effet c'est moi
c'est moi j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé
[Applaudissements]